This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I have a little bit of a different episode for you guys, one that is quite vulnerable. It has been a while since I have given you guys a mental health update.
And if you have been with me for this whole journey since the beginning of the show, you'll know that when I first started, I spoke super openly about my own mental health. This is, of course, a psychology podcast. Psychology is in the name. And I don't think that it comes as a surprise that, you know, being so passionate about this stuff does come from kind of. a personal experience. And since the beginning, I have not been shy about talking about my own mental health. You know, I did an episode on my own experiences with antidepressants,
you know, maybe a couple of years ago now. And, you know, it feels really personal to come online, come on to, come into your ears, I guess, and talk incredibly candidly about something that we are often very private about. And sometimes I think it's oversharing. Sometimes I wish that, you know, I hadn't spoken about it earlier in my career or when I first started this podcast. But then there are other times when I hear other people having these conversations about their struggles with anxiety and with depression and with whatever they're going through.
And it really helps me. It really helps me to see these people that I in my. whose work I love, who I just respect, kind of let us peek behind the curtain and show me and show their audiences that life is not perfect in that no matter what their kind of online persona is, no matter what they're talking about, the advice they're giving what they're showing, they have their own stuff. Each of us has their own stuff. And, you know, I think that it's seeing the benefit that that has for me that makes me want to talk about it more. And I kind of had this realization the other day that if we all kind of wait for other people
to reduce the stigma, nobody is ever going to say anything and nobody is ever going to speak up because there will never be an example set. There will never be somebody to base our experiences off or to base the acceptance that we will receive from our experiences off. So that's kind of what I wanted to do today. just to sit down with you guys and just give you an update about how I'm going, about what's been happening in my life, what's been impacting and influencing my mental health, what's been working. I really want to bring that kind of positive aspect to things. What's actually been
working and what is my deal with medication? Am I still taking my antidepressants? The answer is no. And I want to kind of just explore why that was the right decision for me. And I do want to say very quickly, this is, once again, an incredibly personal episode. It's about my life and my experiences. Please do not take anything that I say in this episode as, I guess, advice for you. You know, maybe it is helpful hearing my story. It doesn't necessarily mean that what I'm doing might be what you need to do or not do or that my journey is going to be identical to yours, you know, whether you are early on in your mental health journey, whether you are a long way in like me, whether, you know, you're just listening because you care
or because you have a friend or a family member who's going through this. I think it's just about having a sense of community around what is such a highly prevalent experience in our 20s and beyond. So to kind of catch you guys up, which sounds so weird to say, but yeah, to catch you guys up, I've been struggling with anxiety and, depression for a very long time since I was, I don't know, 16 years old and, you know, that was almost a decade ago. So I've definitely been around the block with it. And I think a unique part about my experience personally was that I had a lot of shame for a long time around the fact that I didn't look depressed, right? That, you know, I was still able to be very high functioning. I was still able to go to
university and do really well. I was still able to work full time. I was still able to run this podcast and run a business and run my life and have very fruitful relationships. And for a while, I just kind of felt like because I had developed such routine coping mechanisms that meant that I could kind of, you know, live this life where it looked like nothing was wrong. And then I was always happy and everything was going really great, that maybe if I kind of just stopped talking about it, that would be reality. Or kind of on the other side of the coin, that I didn't have a right to talk about it because people kind of had it worse. And I think those thoughts often came to me when everything was going really, really well. And that is the thing about life. Yes, bad days are promised, but good days are
also promised. That is what we don't remember is that on this like mental health roller coaster, which is what I like to call it, there is kind of this weird spectrum between almost forgetting about it sometimes, forgetting about, you know, the dark thoughts forgetting about not wanting to get out of bed, forgetting about the crippling anxiety when you can. And then like the worst days of your life. Like it feels like the kind of sliding, like the sliding, like the sliards. or the distance between those two extremes of mental health, it can switch between them almost overnight. And it's the days in between when you do feel kind of normal that go by the quickest.
And I would say a few months ago, when I was, you know, riding this said roller coaster, I felt very much like I was going down. Like I was getting to the point of really pushing myself kind of into a cave, kind of into a dark space. And the way that I kind of knew that that was happening was I was becoming incredibly detached from reality. And I know that sounds really, really scary, but I think that it's just something that I'm used to in a sense. And yes, it is still terrifying. But I feel like because it's happened so many times, because I can see it as the beginning of a downhill for me, that I've become quite neutral about the experience. And when I
say becoming detached from reality. I don't mean psychosis. I don't mean hallucinations. I mean that it feels like there is this foggy wall between me and everything going on in my life. That means my relationship. That means my friendships. That means with my work, with my family, with my experiences. It feels like it feels like if somebody said to me, this is a dream. This isn't real. It wouldn't take that much convincing for me. agree with them and for me to be like oh yeah you're totally right i'm dreaming right now like there's something about this that feels off the other sign to me that i think my mental health is getting worse is that i become very existential and big questions like ideas around death like the ideas around purpose become very very scary and when they pop into my mind
as, you know, trains of thought often do, it just feels like as soon as they're there, they are the only thing that I can think about and that they take up the whole space and I cannot escape them. This is often, you know, I say it as if it's like a very instantaneous thing and that one moment I'm not thinking about it,
the next moment I am. No, it's often like certain things in my environment that will really trigger this for me. Certain movies, certain songs, just like certain conversations, and I become hyper-aware and hyper-focused on avoiding those triggers on like avoiding, for example, the Truman Show, that is a movie that I just know that I can't watch when like my mental health is going really poorly because I will, it's very easy to like be like, is that real?
Is that true? Like, is that what's happening to me? So it's kind of like the best way I can describe it is that the film, And the layer between reality and fiction or fear becomes quite thin. And if you are somebody who has a similar experience to me, if you're somebody who has struggled with good days and bad days when it comes to their mental health, you will know that once you've kind of been to the other side of that divide, once you have, like, lived in that, I don't know, like that world of just like,
chaos and fear and just like disassociation you realize how quickly and how easily it is for you to pass over to that side of things and so it can become very difficult to live life and to feel present because you are kind of in like this survival mode where you are there's some part of your brain that it's just beating back fear and just beating back those dark thoughts and beating back all those intrusive feelings and ideas that just kind of threatened to bubble up. So yes, sorry, that was a very intense tangent, but a couple months ago I really noticed that that was kind of taking hold. And there was a few things that really triggered it for me. It's often, I often think that I'm somebody who is very good at managing stress. And I am not. I don't know how I have convinced
myself. Like I went to the doctor the other day, the doctor the other day and they were like, have you had any like moments of stress and I was like no not really you know I just like finished a book and I just like moved and you know I just like moved into a house by myself and like yeah like all these big life changes have happened in the past year but no I'm not stressed and the thing is is that I am good at processing stress because I am good at making it invisible to myself I am good at making it a non-problem but that doesn't mean that it doesn't go away I think stress is a lot like energy where it can never like unless you fully sit with it and let it live out its path it does not disappear it just moves to somewhere else in your life or somewhere else in your body so I was
super overwhelmed with that I was definitely burnt out and I mentioned I've already told you guys this that I finished my book and it's not coming out for a while but what essentially happened was I finished the book I got immediately sick like for four weeks I had tonsillitis for four weeks ridiculous and then i experienced just this like deep sense of sadness and that's the only way that i can describe it and i was looking into it i'm very you know because i was curious i was like you know it's funny that this is you know my job is to like think about the psychology of our 20s but i actually also do a lot of it in my own life and a lot of investigation and i came across this like idea of gold medal syndrome, which seems very timely considering the Olympics are just about to start.
Very excited for that, but a side note, sidebar. There is this concept of gold medal syndrome that's very common amongst like Olympic athletes. That's where it came from where there are these people who spend a great deal of time, sometimes their whole lives, wanting to be the best or wanting to finish something, wanting to win that gold medal. That is like the focus of every moment of their waking hours, every day. of their life, everything they eat, everything they do is directed towards this one goal. And when
they achieve it, they realize that it is quite empty. And not only is it quite empty, but if everything in your life has been towards a destination, life seemingly kind of ends at that point. You never think about after. You never think about, you know, what comes next. And I'm definitely not comparing my situation to literally being the best athlete in the world. But it was very much like, okay, this is what I've always wanted. Like, this is the opportunity of a lifetime. I'm just going to put my head down and I'm just going to work towards this goal. And when I'm done, that's it.
Like, what's next? When you're done, what? And it's, I was speaking to my friend, Alex, about this the other day. And I was saying, when you are somebody who has puts a lot of pressure on themselves, who has high functioning anxiety, it's very difficult to ever be satisfied with what you have accomplished or done so far. And so I finished the book, I got sick, and then the fear kind of started up again of like, okay, what's next?
But also, like, was that even good? Like, what's my life without a project? What is my life without something to keep my mind preoccupy? And I think that that is what it is at the end of the day. It is needing something to keep my brain focused. It's like when you put an iPad in front of a kid so that they don't like have a look at the world and like cry over it. That's what I was doing with all of these projects.
I was putting an iPad in front of me. That's what it was. And so yeah, I kind of just ended up pushing myself a little bit too hard and really ending up in a little bit of a ditch on the side of the road for a couple of, for a month, for a month or so a couple of months. And this kind of also coincided with a decision to go off my medication. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle. to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either.
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I've been on antidepressants for, I think, around three and a half years. And when I went on them, I was in a really bad space.
I was super low. I had been in hospital. I don't think I've ever said that before. but I was just, I was not well. I was really, really sick. And I had reached like a crisis point. I went to my doctor, you know, there was a lot of discussions happening around that time. And like one of the first lines of defense, I think, against moments like that is they put you on medication.
And at the time, I was so like looking for any solution to like the chaos in my brain that I was like, this will have to, this will have to do. This is what I need. Just give me it. Just give me an answer. give me an antidote. I spoke about this in my episode on antidepressants, but when I first went on them, it was awful. I'll be completely transparent. It was awful because of like the physical reaction that my body and my brain had to them because I was on SSRIs, which is selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors. Essentially what those are meant to do is mean that there is more serotonin available for your neurotranser.
for your neurons to essentially use. So, you know, if sadness, depression is caused by a lack of serotonin, if we make more of it available by preventing our synapses from taking it back, meaning that there's more in that space, then the sadness is gone, right? It really takes a biological approach to our mental health. The thing about that, though, is that if it's the case that your brain does not have a of serotonin, providing it with more, or making more serotonin available to it is going to have some other reactions. And what I found was that I was just dizzy all the time. I, what was another thing?
I was tired, constantly tired. I would wake up and by like 11 a.m., I just, I could not keep my eyes open. I was fuzzy. I was nauseous. After like around two months, I would say, that kind of went away. And that was three and a half years ago. And since then, it has been a daily thing that I do. I take my medication. And I haven't really thought anything of it. I definitely did experience some emotional numbness at the beginning. But the further along I got, that kind of went away. I've always thought, is it because my emotions came back and rebalanced or is it because I just got used to this being the norm. You get too deep in the weeds with that question. You will never get your way out. But basically I think the purpose that medication served for me, because I think it is really important,
I will say that. I'll get to my decision to go off it in just a second, but I do think that it's really valuable and it does really help some people. And if it is something that is like offered to you do your research, but definitely like for me it helped. And it helped because it was a security net, right? There are a bunch of like coping skills and strategies that I needed to learn that at the that weren't going to help me without the security net. Right. Like I needed, it's like practicing a new trick. Like I needed the safety of knowing that everything was kind of working in my brain. and trying out these new tactics wouldn't be like life or death. I couldn't fall. I couldn't fail.
And so I got better at them. I built them up. And now it just feels like I've got the tricks. I don't need the safety net anymore. And I want to know what life is like without this medication. Having been on it for such a long time, knowing when I went on it that I would be on it for such a long time, I'm in a completely new chapter of my life now.
When I went on them, I was, you know, still in Canberra. I was still, I was just finished uni. I was, you know, in a different relationship. I had different friends. I had a different financial situation. I had different job. Everything about me was very, very different. And I was also, and I was just, I was very vulnerable.
And I was very, and I'm going to say this word. weak and I'm not saying weak in the sense of like I was weak because I was struggling with my mental health and I'm strong now. I was weak in that I had just been carrying this huge thing for so long and I'd run out of strength right. I'd run out of energy because of everything that was like accumulating in my life that was putting pressure on me. Now I have my I have my coping mechanisms first of all. I know how to manage my anxiety. I went on my SSRIs for both anxiety and depression. I know how to ride the wave. I know how to manage it. I know how to calm myself down. I know how to interrupt irrational and intrusive thoughts. I know what I need to implement when my mood starts to
turn. And I also have a stable relationship with like the most amazing supportive person. I have a job that brings me fulfillment. I have very safe and secure and loving friendships, which I don't necessarily think that I had back then. And this is the most important thing. I have peace. I have a real peace to my life. And oh my gosh, saying that makes me want to like knock wood because I don't want that to go away. But I think when you're in your early 20s, right, everything is just so fucking chaotic. Everything is a mess and there is drama and there are friendship breakups and there is upheaval and there are transitions and that has been the last three years and I feel like I've
come out of the tunnel and I've just seen this whole new world and I don't need what I had before I don't need the drugs. I don't need it. So what has that been like going off it? So this is not medical advice, but a fact about weaning yourself off antidepressants is that if you stop cold turkey, you are going to suffer. Like it is going to be hard. And having been on them for so long, it really was not recommended. Like it's not recommended to just be like, okay, like I'm doing amazing. I'm just going to stop this right now with absolutely no health advice or like no expert opinion or no assistance. So I wanted to taper off them. I wanted to kind of put in a plan and I talked to my doctor about it.
I was like, okay, let's do this across like two to three months and we're going to slowly lower my dosage and then we're going to slowly lower what I'm taking until eventually like one day I just don't need it anymore. Like I just, I stopped taking it all together. And yes, there will still be symptoms, but there'll be lesser. Let me tell you, I do not know how I would have done this just going off all at once because the the things like the experiences that I've had, it's really made me realize that these drugs like do actually change something very like fundamental in your brain. I've been having like brain zaps and I
don't know if you know what this is but I'll be like going around my day and it would just be like somebody has just like sent a shockwave through my brain to my fingertips. I have been feeling really, really dizzy and like my vision has been really disturbed and also really irritable like super irritable super short unable to really like engage with people that was kind of like the last week last couple weeks like I'm over that hump now I can see things really like changing for the better but it takes a toll on your relationships and those around you as well and it took a toll on kind of work and on like passion and like my hobbies because it just felt like, okay, I'm having to adjust to this like new way of going about things and I have to adjust to essentially what is a withdrawal,
a withdrawal from something that I can acknowledge held me up for many, many years. So that's kind of been where I'm at with that whole experience. It's been three and a half years. I'm going off my antidepressants. I'm going off my other medications as well, not yet. but in the next couple of months it's a slow process and I feel like I've been complaining I'm actually feeling really really good about things I'm feeling really really good about things and the reason why is because I spoke about that kind of hard period I was having a few like a month back a few months back
这是对某种曾经支撑了我很多很多年的状态的戒断。所以这就是我经历这一切后的感受。已经三年半了。我正在戒掉抗抑郁药。我还要戒掉其他的药，虽然还没开始，但在接下来的几个月里会进行，这是一个缓慢的过程。我觉得我好像一直在抱怨，但其实我现在的感觉真的、真的很好，我感觉真的、真的很好，原因就是我谈到了一个月前、几个月前经历的那段艰难时期。
my gosh my time ends all wild up earlier this year I spoke about how I was having that hard time after the book when I got sick and I just feel like it was hard it was difficult I was sad, I was losing touch, but I got through it. And I got through it in a way that I think I would not have been able to do before, and it made me realize that I was ready. So these are some of the other things that have been like really, really helping me. And I know some of them will sound cliche, but it's like an army of tools, right? It's not just like one tactic is going to fight all the battles for me.
天哪，今年早些时候我的时间过得太疯狂了，我谈到了出书后生病时是如何度过那段艰难时期的，我只是觉得那段时光很艰难、很痛苦，我很伤感，甚至有点迷失自我，但我挺过来了。而且我挺过来的方式，我觉得换作以前的我是绝对做不到的，这让我意识到我已经准备好了。所以这些是其他一些真正、真正帮助过我的事情。我知道其中一些听起来可能有点老套，但这就像是一支由各种工具组成的军队，对吧？不能仅靠一种战术来打赢所有的仗。
It is layered. I think having that foundational support system is amazing and like real shout out to my partner. He is the most beautiful, wonderful person and like I don't know what I would do without him. And yeah, it's just like a crazy experience to have that kind of healthy, sustaining love that's just like it's just like a big warm hug. Like you're going to get through anything that you're getting through and, you know, it's so different. from what it was like when I really first started acknowledging these problems when I didn't have that. And the person I was with was, you know, probably contributing rather than helping. So that's a big thing.
这是有层次的。我觉得拥有那种基础的支持系统真的太棒了，在这里我要特别感谢我的伴侣。他是这个世界上最美好、最棒的人，如果没有他，我真不知道该怎么办。是的，拥有那种健康、持久的爱真的是一种奇妙的体验，它就像一个温暖的大大的拥抱。让你觉得无论正在经历什么都能挺过去，而且，你知道的，这和我刚开始意识到这些问题、身边却没有这种支持的时候截然不同。当时在我身边的那个人，你知道的，可能不仅没有帮忙，反而在起负面作用。所以这是一个很大的改变。
But the other thing is I've been doing this thing that a friend taught me called my smile file. I get really kind of held up in the details of life, particularly like obsessing and ruminating over negative things. And I think that if you're somebody with depression or if you're going through a depressive episode, that is a huge component of it. It's not just like, you know, it's not that an uneven number of bad things happen to people with depression versus people who don't have depression. Sometimes, of course, there are triggering factors and triggering experiences, but it's not like the world hates people with depression more.
但另一件事是，我一直在做一件朋友教我的事情，叫做我的“微笑文件夹”。我很容易陷入生活的细节中无法自拔，尤其是对消极的事情过度执食和反复琢磨。我想如果你是一个抑郁症患者，或者你正在经历抑郁发作，这会是其中很大一部分原因。这不仅仅是说，你知道的，抑郁症患者遇到坏事的几率比不得抑郁症的人更高。有时候，当然会有诱发因素和触发经历，但并不是说这个世界对抑郁症患者抱有更多的恶意。
It's not like the universal God is giving them more experiences. It's that I found that I just tend to focus on those bad things a lot more. and it just feels a lot heavier and it feels like I can see my friends be like oh yeah this shit thing happened and like I can move past it and for me it's like no I can't so what I've been doing the counteract that is called a smile file so anytime something good happens anytime I get like a lovely message from one of you guys you guys are the best like I take a screenshot of it I take a photo of something beautiful that I've seen and I put it in a folder so that when I'm sitting on my at the end of the night and maybe just feeling really terrible.
并不是宇宙中的神给了他们更多的苦难。我发现我只是更倾向于把注意力放在那些糟糕的事情上。这让我觉得事情沉重得多，我看到朋友们经历了一件糟糕的事，心想“哦，好吧”，然后就能抛在脑后继续前行，而对我和来说却觉得“不，我做不到”。所以为了对抗这种情绪，我一直在做的一件事叫做“微笑文件夹”——所以每当有好事发生，每当收到你们当中某人发来的暖心信息（你们真的是最棒的！）——我都会截屏保存，或者拍下我看到的某个美丽的瞬间，然后把它们放进一个文件夹里。这样当我深夜独自坐在那里，也许正感觉糟透了的时候。
There is this immediate space I can go to that is just everything positive in my life. And it's grounding. It's really grounding to have like the reality that I live a good life presented to me right there. The other thing that I think was one of the, I don't think I know this was one of the things I really worked on the last three years was like reworking my negative beliefs. and learning that how I perceive those negative thoughts is a choice. Those negative experiences are always going to be there.
我立刻就能打开这个空间，里面装满了生活中的所有积极事物。这能让我脚踏实地。直面我其实过着好生活这个现实，真的能让人内心安定。另一件我认为是——不，我不是觉得，我知道这是我过去三年真正努力做的事情之一——就是重塑我的负面信念。并学着认识到，我如何看待这些负面想法其实是一种选择。那些负面经历总是会发生。
Bad things are always going to happen. Bad thoughts might always happen. But how I think about them is going to determine what I do with those things. And please do not misconstrue my words and think that I'm saying, like, you can choose to be happy or you can choose to be sad. Absolutely not. it's that I can choose to think about them in a way that is constructive or unproductive. Let me give you an example and we've been vulnerable so far. Let's go even deeper.
坏事总会发生。坏想法也可能随时出现。但对它们的看法将决定我如何应对这些事情。请不要曲解我的意思，以为我在说“你可以选择快乐，或者你可以选择悲伤”。绝对不是这样。我的意思是，我可以选择用一种具有建设性或非生产性的方式来思考它们。让我举个例子，既然我们前面已经表现得足够坦诚了，那我们就再深入探讨一下。
Another component of this is that I have been struggling at times with like resentment towards my friendships and feeling like, you know, there are certain relationships that perhaps I've outgrown and that there is, you know, there is an inequality there and perhaps the love that I give them and the love that I'm receiving back, it's just, I think it's just part of life, you know, you're not always going to be on the same page as certain people, and there was definitely like a point where I realized that perhaps I was giving a little bit too much to people who didn't, not that they didn't deserve it,
其中的另一个部分是，我有时会挣扎于对友谊的某种怨恨，觉得，你知道的，某些关系可能我已经超越了，彼此之间存在着某种不平等，也许我付出的爱和我收到的爱并不对等。我觉得这只是生活的一部分吧，你知道的，你不可能永远和某些人在同一个频段上。而且确实有一个时间点，我意识到自己可能给得太多了，给那些并不——倒不是说他们不配，
everybody is deserving of all the love that you can give them, but that maybe that love should be reserved for people who were, willing to reciprocate the fact that I make plans, who were willing to support me as, you know, as a business, as a creator, as a person, you know, when I did cool stuff, they were willing to be like, that's cool and they were willing to get out and support it. And so there was definitely a bit of resentment, and I'll admit that. We're doing an episode on that soon, navigating resentment. And I think previously I would have been like, wow, I'm so angry.
每个人都值得你付出所有的爱，但也许这些爱应该留给那些愿意回报我的人，那些愿意支持我的人——无论是作为一家企业、一个创作者，还是作为一个普通人。你知道的，当我做出一些酷炫的成就时，他们愿意说“这很酷”，并且愿意走出来支持我。所以心中确实产生了一些怨恨，我承认这一点。我们很快就会出一期关于这个主题的节目，探讨如何应对怨恨。我想以前的我可能会觉得：“哇，我好生朋友的气，
at my friend because they really didn't show up for me. And why didn't they show up for me? Probably because I'm a bad person. Probably because I did something that, like, upset them. Probably because, you know, I don't deserve love. And probably because I'm doomed to be lonely, you can see the thought spiral, right? It's like second nature to spiral. And the trick for me was to be like, all right, what's that first negative thought that's
因为他们真的没有在我需要的时候出现。为什么他们不出现？大概是因为我是一个糟糕的人。大概是因为我做了什么事惹他们生气了。大概是因为，你知道的，我不配得到爱。大概是因为我注定要孤独终老。”你能看出这种思维的螺旋式下降吧？陷入消极循环就像是本能一样。而对我的诀窍在于：好的，那个引发连锁反应的最初负面想法到底是什么？
going to set off the chain reaction? like I am not worthy of love or, you know, I've done something wrong, I'm a bad person, and just look at that thought and be completely and entirely rational about it. What evidence is there for that being the case? Where did I think, when did I pick up on this fact that, you know, the fact that my friend isn't supporting me or showing up for me means that I'm a bad person? Is that actually the only explanation and the best explanation? And then it's also, you know, even going a step back and being like, okay, yeah, I really resent my friend for, you know, I feel like they don't care about me.
比如“我不配得到爱”，或者“我做错了事，我是个坏人”。然后就去审视这个想法，并对它保持完全、彻底的理性。有什么证据能证明事实确实如此吗？我是在哪里、在什么时候开始得出这样一个结论的——即我的朋友不支持我、不在我需要时出现，就意味着我是一个坏人？这真的是唯一的解释，或者说最好的解释吗？然后，你知道的，甚至还要退一步想：“好吧，是的，我确实对我的朋友感到怨恨，因为我觉得他们不在乎我。”
And instead of being like, that says everything about me and that's going to ruin my day and ruin my life and completely turn, you know, everything to shit, it's like, okay, I'm going to accept that and be neutral about it. And all I'm going to do is change my expectations and just change my opinion towards. a situation. Yeah, it's not fun. It's not great. And that's it. There's nothing more to it than that. The situation is contained. The situation is just the situation. It's not my life. So that has been something that's been really, really helpful. And obviously, like, it's a lot more complicated than that. It was a whole process of, like, cognitive behavioral therapy that I absolutely recommend. But then there are also behavioral changes. I hate to be cliche. But I've been exercising a lot. gosh, if it is not true that it does make you feel better. It's not a cure. It's definitely not a cure.
与其认为“这说明了我的一切，这会毁了我的的一天、毁了我的生活，让一切都变成一团糟”，不如这样想：“好吧，我接受这种情绪，并对它保持中立。”我唯一要做的就是改变我的期望，改变我对这个局面的看法。是的，这并不有趣，也不是什么美妙的体验。但事情就是这样，仅此而已，没有别的了。这个情况是有局限的，它只是一个客观情况，而不是我的整个人生。所以这种方法真的、真的很有用。当然，这要复杂得多。这是一个完整的认知行为疗法（CBT）过程，我绝对向大家推荐。但除此之外，还有行为上的改变。我讨厌老套，但我确实一直在大量运动。天哪，运动真的能让人感觉好点，这绝对是千真万确的。它不是什么灵丹妙药，绝对不是。
But again, it's a strategy. It's a strategy for releasing a lot of pent-up anxiety. And for me, actually what really helped was when I was first like, you know, when everything first started happening, I was having a lot of panic attacks. And when I first started getting like that racing heart, those symptoms, that was really scary. And I felt like as soon as my heart rate was up, As soon as my blood was running, I was going to have a panic attack. And what exercise really helped me realize was that I can activate that same physiological state myself and the worst case scenario doesn't happen. And I can actually get myself back down.
但再强调一次，它是一种策略。是一种释放大量积压焦虑的策略。对我而言，实际上真正起作用的是在我刚开始出现状况的时候，当时一切刚开始发生，我经历了大量的恐慌发作。当我第一次开始心跳加速、出现那些症状时，真的很吓人。我觉得只要我的心率一上升，只要血液加速循环，我就会马上恐慌发作。而运动真正帮我意识到的是：我可以自己主动激活这种生理状态，而最坏的情况并没有发生。我其实可以让自己平静下来。
I can, you know, get my heart rate down. I can calm myself down. I can cool myself down. So that was also a component. It wasn't just the physical endorphins. It was the mental exercise and the mental control. that exercise gave me. And I also have kind of turned down drinking a lot. Drinking for me, and I've spoken about this before, has definitely been a bit of a mental and psychological crutch
我能（你知道的）让心率降下来，让自己冷静下来，让自己冷却下来。所以这也是其中的一部分。不仅是身体上的内啡肽，还有运动带来的精神锻炼和精神控制力。我也在很大程度上减少了饮酒。对我来说，喝酒——我以前也谈过这个——绝对是一种精神和心理上的拐杖。
because it does really slow everything down. It is a depressant. That's like, that's the kind of drug it is. Alcohol is a drug and it's a depressant. So when I was super, super anxious, it would make me feel like a lot more in control. It would make me feel like, you know, okay, well, I can't be, you know, those negative thoughts and those spirals about death and about the end of the world and world and about my, you know, lovability and lovability about my, you know, my worthiness and all those things. I can't think about that for that long when I've had like four glasses of wine because I'm going to be on the next thing pretty soon.
因为它确实能让一切慢下来。酒精是一种镇静剂，这就是它的本质。酒精是一种药物，而且是一种镇静剂。所以当我超级、超级焦虑的时候，喝酒会让我感觉更有掌控感。它会让我觉得：“好吧，我不会再去想那些消极的想法，不会再陷入关于死亡、关于世界末日、关于我是否讨人喜欢、关于我的自我价值等等诸如此类的思维漩涡了。”当我喝了四杯酒之后，我就不会再想那么久了，因为我很快就会把注意力转到别的事情上去。
So it was definitely a crutch and although it reduces my anxiety in the moment, it's like The next day I wake up and I am incredibly anxious and incredibly sad and incredibly down because that is the chemical reaction that alcohol is going to have on my brain. And so I just didn't want to be reliant on that anymore and I didn't want it to be this yo-yo coping mechanism that, you know, reduced the mental tension one moment and then just like accelerated it the next. and it's been great. It's honestly been great.
所以这绝对是一个拐杖。尽管它能在当下缓解我的焦虑，但代价是：第二天醒来时，我会感到无比焦虑、无比悲伤、无比低落，因为这就是酒精对我的大脑产生的化学反应。所以我只是不想再依赖它了，我不想让它成为那种让精神紧张在这一刻缓解、下一刻却加速爆发的“溜溜球”式应对机制。现在感觉太棒了。老实说，真的太棒了。
I did an episode on this. I think at the start of the year, that was like why we should quit drinking, should you quit drinking in your 20s? And it's not that like alcohol has no place in my life at all. I never drink. I do still drink, but what I've been doing is choosing like one day a week that I get to drink.
我做过一期关于这个的节目。我想是在今年年初，主题是“我们为什么要戒酒，你在20多岁时应该戒酒吗？”并不是说酒精在我的生活中完全没有立足之地，我从不喝酒了。我其实还是会喝，但我现在做的是每周只选一天可以喝酒。
And it's not like I'm going to go out and binge drink on that day, but it's about really repositioning alcohol as like a celebration. or like, yes, it is a part of my life, but it's a special part of my life. It's like something that I'll only do if I'm going out for like a really fun dinner with a friend or like date night with my boyfriend or my mom's in town or a birthday. Instead of it, you know, being something that I'm like, oh, should I have a drink when I'm home alone? Like I just don't do that anymore because if I only have one day to drink, I want to use that day the best that I can. So, yeah, those have been my strategies.
并不是说在那一天我会疯狂酗酒，而是重新将酒精定位为一种庆祝。或者说，是的，它是生活的一部分，但它是生活中的一个特殊部分。就像只有在和朋友去吃一顿非常开心的晚餐、和男朋友约会、我妈妈来镇上看我，或者过生日时，我才会去喝一点。而不是让它变成一种“我在家孤单一人时，要不要喝一杯”的东西——我现在再也不会那样做了，因为如果我一周只有一天能喝酒，我希望把那一天用得最有价值。所以，是的，这些就是我的策略。
those have been the things that I've been changing. And also just working with a therapist, just working on like, you know, being somebody who is responsible having a good life. And I know that sounds really intense, maybe. I don't know what you're... I don't know. I'm thinking about what you're thinking about my words,
这些就是我一直在做出的改变。还有就是和治疗师一起合作，努力成为一个对美好生活负责任的人。我知道这听起来可能有点强烈。我不知道你在……我不知道你对我的话有什么想法，
which is strange. But I just want to feel like I'm in control of creating a good life for myself. and the only way that I can prove that to myself is by actually doing it and by actually making things better for me, whether that is exercising, whether that is not drinking, whether that is prioritizing good, loving, sustainable and just like fulfilling friendship over temporary associations. You know, that is a choice. And I think when it comes to your mental health, there is so much that you don't get to control, that the things that you do get to control feel really, really important and feel really, really
这感觉有点奇怪。但我只是想觉得自己有能力掌控并为自己创造美好的生活。而我能向自己证明这一点的唯一方法，就是付诸行动，让事情变得更好——无论是通过运动、不喝酒，还是把优质、充满爱意、可持续且充实的友谊置于那些短暂的泛泛之交之上。你知道，这是一种选择。我认为当谈到心理健康时，有很多事情是你无法掌控的，正因如此，那些你能够掌控的事情就会显得非常、非常重要，非常有
significant. And I just want to take as much of that as I can and to have as much agency as I can. And, you know, I just feel like I'm doing a lot better. And maybe, maybe that will change. Maybe the roller coaster will suddenly turn a corner. But I feel prepared. And it's kind of emotional to say that because I just feel like for a long time, I've always felt that I was just kind of strapped in. And whatever life wanted to throw me, whatever my mental health wanted to throw me, I just had to like bear it.
意义。我只想尽可能多地抓住这些掌控权，尽可能多地拥有自主权。你知道的，我只是觉得自己现在状态好多了。也许，也许这种状态会改变。也许过山车又会突然转弯。但我已经准备好了。说出这句话让我觉得有点情绪激动，因为我觉得在很长一段时间里，我都觉得自己只是被牢牢绑在上面。无论生活想向我抛来什么，无论我的心理健康状况想折腾出什么风浪，我都只能默默忍受。
And I just feel like I'm bigger and I'm stronger now. And I have my strength back and I have a say and I have things to do and things to do. and things too. Like I kind of have a voice and I can kind of yell back at it a little bit. So I hope that has maybe resonated with you. I hope that this has kind of helped you.
而我现在觉得自己变得更强大、更坚韧了。我找回了自己的力量，我有发言权，有事情要做，有事情要处理，还有事情要去完成。我有了一种声音，我甚至可以对那些负面情绪大声回吼了。所以，我希望这些能引起你们的共鸣。我希望这些能对你们有所帮助。
I don't know what you're going through. It might not be the same as me. You might not relate. But maybe there is somebody who does and I just wanted to kind of share that it was really bad once, it's better now and it might get bad again, but it's going to be okay.
我不知道你们正在经历什么。可能和我的情况不一样。你们或许无法感同身受。但也许有人能懂，我只是想分享这样一件事：曾经情况真的很糟糕，但现在变好了，虽然以后可能还会变糟，但没关系，一切都会好起来的。
And I'm, you know, I lived through it. and I'm doing so much better and I'm really happy. And that is that. That is really the mental health update for you guys. So thank you for making it this far. Thank you for listening. And yeah, thank you for just being there. Thank you for giving me my dream job.
而我（你知道的）挺过来了，现在过得好得多，而且我真的很高兴。事情就是这样。这就是给你们的心理健康近况更新。非常感谢大家听到了最后。谢谢你们的聆听。还有，谢谢你们一直都在，谢谢你们给了我这份梦想中的工作。
Gosh, this is a sappy episode. But you know what? Sometimes you just got to do it. Sometimes it can't be all scientific. We've got to be in our fields a little bit. We've got to be really pulling the curtain back on like the 20-something life. So if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
天哪，这一期节目太煽情了。但你知道吗？有时你就是得这么做。生活不能总是那么理性科学。我们有时也得展露真实的情感，彻底揭开20多岁年轻人生活的神秘面纱。所以，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随手在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。
Make sure that you are following along for new episodes, happier episodes, more informative episodes. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you want me to talk about this more, if you want me to talk about this less, if you have something that you're going through that you want to know the psychology behind, please feel free to DM me at that psychology podcast. Make sure you're following us over there. and we will be back on Friday for another episode until then. Be safe, be kind, and be gentle to yourself, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
确保关注我们，以便收听更多新节目、更快乐的节目以及更有启发的节目。如果你有什么节目建议，想让我多聊聊这个，或者少聊聊这个，或者你正经历着某种困境并想了解背后的心理学原理，请随时在 Instagram 上私信我 @thatpsychology podcast。一定要去关注我们的账号。我们周五会带着另一期节目回归。在此之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是身边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happy, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在这个奇异的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。即数字“2%”。欢迎收听《回顾过往》（Look Back at it）播客。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
对1979年来说，那是对我而言意义重大的一刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年头。我认为对黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《回顾过往》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）。这个空间专属于黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而这一切都是在一位懂行的执照专业人士的陪伴下进行的。
How many men carry a suit are honest? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人在带上西装铠甲的同时能保持诚实？这向世界释放出一个信号：你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《艰难成长的教训》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
大批互联网侦探介入调查，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个男人也遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于迎来了她的报应。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their. own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《受困的爱》播客。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说：相信你的好闺蜜。请在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《闺蜜，相信我》（Trust Me, Babe）。这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。